so there was a recent consumer
confidence survey that said that 87
percent of democrats think the economy
is good or like positive sentiment
while only 37 percent of republicans did
and you noted that this was the largest
gulf
in terms of perception of
the economic trajectory between parties
that you had ever seen 50 percent
but then
even more troubling
is that this wasn't only on one side or
the other that back in 2019
the gulf actually cut the other
direction where republicans thought the
economy was great democrats thought it
sucked by a margin of 47
so the university of michigan has been
doing this consumer survey for like 60
70 years they basically ask a bunch of
people
how do you think the economy is going
and since the 1980s they've been
breaking it down democrat republican
independent right
between 1980
and
2017 there had never been more than a
30-point gap between the way democrats
and republicans saw the economy right
and since 2017 it's just gone completely
berserk that if a republican is the
president
just about other republicans say the
economy is great and a lot of the
democrats say the economy is bad and
then when a democrat is president all
the democrats say that the economy is
good and all the republicans say the
economy is bad that's only a slight
exaggeration but that's basically what
we started to see
we used to
partially decide whether or not we
thought our party was doing a good job
by first looking to the economy but now
we decide if the economy is good by
first looking to the party that's in
power ideology is the
pair of glasses that everybody is
wearing and as a result you might not as
well even ask people how good the
economy is you might as well just tell
them hey do you like biden or not
because once once i hear the answer to
that question everything else that i ask
you about reality will simply flow
downstream of that comment
[Music]
[Music]
this week on the podcast one of the
people i turn to to understand economics
technology and the media he is the
author of hitmakers the host of the
podcast brand new plain english and a
staff writer at the atlantic which is
one of my favorite news sources derek
thompson joins us on the podcast
[Music]
it is a thrill to welcome to the podcast
one of the most talented economics and
technology and culture journalists
around
host of the brand new podcast on the
rigor network plain english you probably
know him from the atlantic derrick
thompson welcome derek hey it's great to
be here thank you derek
i
reference your work all the time when
i'm trying to figure out what's going on
in the economy uh you know you and i
have known each other for a while you've
written several books about different
aspects of
the hit maker
economy
so i'm going to lead off with a question
on everyone's mind which i'm sure people
ask you at cocktail parties and the rest
of it much to your chagrin what the hell
is going on with this economy
like what what is it like where are we
right now it's so funny so i we just
recorded a podcast about this and my one
sentence summary of where things stand
is all the good news has an asterisk and
all the bad news has a silver lining so
you pick some piece of good news like
look unemployment is lower now than it
was in any month of 2016. that's an
extraordinary achievement after the
pandemic at the same time one of the
reasons why unemployment is so low is
because we're missing six seven million
people from the labor force uh there is
a large number of people who retired
early because they're afraid of the
pandemic there are people who are
waiting out the pandemic on the
sidelines because they don't feel
comfortable working or they really hate
a job they just quit or maybe they have
a financial cushion and that's obviously
good we don't want to force people to
work starvation jobs but there's piece
of good news that has a little bit of an
asterisk then all the bad news has a
silver lining like look inflation is
real and it's the highest that it's been
in uh
a long time maybe more than 30 years uh
it's higher when you look at like
gasoline prices the year-over-year
inflation rate is one of the highest
prints on record at the same time
the high inflation rate is partly an
evidence of some good things that are
happening a demand is
so much higher than we thought it would
be maybe a year ago people are spending
a lot retail numbers are up restaurants
are roaring back the supply chain can't
yet meet all of this demand and as a
result it's cashing out as high
inflation so the way that i think about
this economy is that you know in the
1970s we invented this port monto of a
stag inflation economy yeah stagnant
jimmy carter inflation that that's like
the
the great fear
yeah this is not circulation this is
kaboom flation this is a booming economy
that is also seeing inflation and i
think it's really important to
distinguish uh the the the bad growth
that we saw in the 1970s from the
accelerating growth that we're seeing
right now coming out of the pandemic a
lot of good stuff is happening but it
all has an asterisk growflation we need
a term uh you know i guess if you're the
biden administration you just want to to
avoid this term stagflation and jimmy
carter redux which i think is the vibe
uh unfortunately we'll return to that a
little bit later on i'm not sure if
kaboom inflation is going to catch
though derek i gotta be honest so so
so we need we need something else like
bullflation i like i don't know work on
it by the end of this conversation let's
try and coin this term you got it yeah
we have boom inflation we got
bullflation
capalflation well there's a lot of
there's a lot of dash relations that we
can throw out there and i'll sort of
have it on i'll have that program
running on background as we speak please
do i know you're capable of multiple
cycles
so
let's dig into
each of the pieces you just described so
you said
headline unemployment reads as being
quite low
but people have dropped out of the
workforce and one of the facts that i
just saw reported that you retweeted
actually was out of ben castleman which
is that we're still missing 4.2 million
jobs since before the pandemic a lot of
that's in hospitality and leisure
so
uh so the first question is
what is going on with these six million
or so people that have left the
workforce and how should we think about
the labor market healthy unhealthy
i think
previously very unhealthy and getting
healthier i mean we basically put the
economy into a forced coma in april
2020. uh so we are coming from a flash
freeze recession in the spring and early
summer of last year and we're coming out
of it we added more than five hundred
thousand jobs last month
that would be an absolute yeah which was
less than what a lot of people were
hoping or projecting from way before so
in absolute terms it's good but it was
it fair to say that people were hoping
for better x months ago is that right i
think if you look at the three-month
running average getting a little bit
technical here but if you look at the
three-month running average right like
the general trend is a little bit slower
than people were hoping but last month's
number was really really strong and i
think we can continue to build on it as
hopefully fingers crossed knocking on
whatever what is available coveted fears
continue to decline vaccines continue to
move through boosters continue to
improve the general level of antibodies
and we don't see the same spike in
deaths this winter that we saw last
winter and there's a lot of reasons to
believe that this winter especially into
early spring we're going to have a
really healthy labor market lots of job
growth and not just job growth andrew
this is something i know that you're
interested in um if you look at wage
growth and where wage growth is the
strongest it's not at the top thank god
it's not the middle it's at the bottom
wages are growing fastest for the low
income and they're growing fastest
because
as leisure and hospitality comes back
online restaurants and uh retailers are
having to raise wages to keep people
working there because otherwise what are
they doing they're quitting great
resignation the most americans on record
just quit their jobs last month and the
period or the sector with the most job
quits was accommodation food services so
hotels and restaurants and bars
you put all this together and my brief
summary is things were really bad last
year they are getting better for sure
they are getting better a little bit
slower than we were hoping and they're
getting better with this other
asterisk which is inflation is higher
than we expected that it would be in
part because supply chains are too
constricted to provide for all the
demand that's coming from the us economy
so to the extent that there is still
pain or lag in the economy uh and we're
we're going to try to
unpack this great resignation which is
on everyone's minds anytime you go out
to eat
or to shop you see health wanted signs
everywhere
you know people are like hey you know
jobs available come come apply
um
and i believe
that's one of the reasons why we're
seeing wages go up at the low end is
people are like well people aren't
applying to jobs it's just like you know
i guess we're gonna have to raise our
wages someone said
in an article employers think that 15
bucks an hour is a lot of money until
they find out that's what mcdonald's is
offering
but so there is this baseline that's
coming up
uh so the folks that
have left those jobs uh and are kind of
waiting to be enticed back in how are
they able to make ends meet do we have a
sense is it because they received
enhanced unemployment benefits uh before
and haven't most of those programs at
this point uh stopped uh applying to the
same level i think it's a really good
question it's a little bit of a mystery
to me why
we see such a large labor force dropout
like six to seven million jobs or people
looking for jobs that is a lot that's
basically the labor force of
pennsylvania that we're missing from the
economy even though overall gdp is
basically higher than it was before the
pandemic started like that is definitely
a mystery that i don't want to pretend i
have 100 of the answer to but if you're
gonna piece together an answer it's
pretty clear to me where the pieces
start they start with savings that
people have from last year because they
weren't going on trips they weren't
doing special stuff because the economy
was shut down it comes from the stimulus
checks obviously as you said it comes
from enhanced unemployment benefits as
you said um you piece it all together
and i can sort of begin to see why you
uh how you have this sort of financial
cushion um but then you move away from
fine from financial cushions and you
also have coven right people might still
be afraid of catching this in a
restaurant or in a hotel so they're not
applying to those jobs you might also
have the fact that because schools are
still a little bit messed up you have
moms and dads who don't want to leave
the house they want to stay home and be
there in case their kid has to
be forced out of school in case you know
school is shut down for a week because
there's a coveted case or two uh so
there there are a bunch of different
health and economic and psychological
reasons why people are sort of holding
out from the economy and i think if you
piece it all together you have the basis
of an explanation for this this labor
shortage mystery i think a lot of it's
burnout i think a lot of it's mental
fatigue lisa like some of the folks i
talked to just
were like screw this and went went home
and then have just been figuring it out
uh and
i see this in a variety of fields i just
saw a piece about how healthcare workers
are burning out which we all understand
but it's not just in that industry it
seems like it's all over there's been a
lot of rethinking i almost feel like we
have this very
strict conditioning that then got broken
during kovid and now when you say to
folks hey you know do what you've always
done a lot of people
are very very hesitant and trying to
figure out a new path a lot of people
moved you know i've seen the relocation
rates uh have been significantly higher
than normal which we can talk a little
bit about when we talk about whether
remote work is here to stay and what the
heck that means
but so yeah so your characterization of
the labor market is like hey it's been
really really sick but it's getting
better
and we're not sure about some of the
um the
adjustments because you know like the
the fact is that there are a few
different pieces to it yeah that's right
i mean i think you you mentioned two
things i think are really important to
talk about a little bit more one is the
fact that people are reassessing exactly
what the role of work should be in their
life they're they're burning out of
their jobs they're taking some time to
rethink their career or rethink uh you
know what they're going to do for a
living
and i don't think that's entirely a bad
thing in large part i think the great
resignation is for workers great it's
wonderful
that people can have an opportunity
to make that calculation i mean in an
economy let's imagine some some sort of
earth to american economy which isn't so
different maybe than earth one where a
lot of americans feel like they don't
have the opportunity to quit if they're
burned out they don't have the
opportunity to quit if they feel like
they just don't want to do their job
anymore they have to work or they're
going to starve and their family will
starve that's not a world that i want
it's not a world that i know it's not a
world that you want especially just in
ubi
um but fortunately with it with this
with these checks and the savings and
unemployment and expanded unemployment
benefits i think people do have this
freedom to have you know a great reset
and then in addition to the great reset
you also have this great reshuffling you
have people moving more than they used
to we had declining migration in the u.s
declining sort of intercity and
interstate migration in the u.s i think
since the 1970s it was a pretty long
period of declining mojo in this country
and in the last two years people are
moving more they're moving to the
suburbs of metros they live in they're
moving between cities i think that's a
good thing too i think that you know i
want an economy where people don't feel
so precarious and so
desperate to work that they can't
experiment a little bit in their life
they can't move to a city to check it
out try it try on a job and quit if they
don't like it and explore the skills
that work best for them and then figure
out which one is their favorite and jump
all into a queer there i want people to
feel that sense of exploration and you
need a little bit i think of of economic
safety net laying in order for people to
experiment
we've laid a lot of net in the last uh
in the last year and a half and as a
result i think you're seeing a healthy
amount of experimentation
[Music]
we're all looking for better ways to do
the things we do every day and you know
what we do every day if we're healthy is
go number two hope you do it every day
and then afterwards if you're like most
of us
you use some toilet paper you wipe but
what if it didn't have to be that way
what if you could
make it cleaner with water
better for the environment more
effective more modern more european more
cosmopolitan
that's what tushy will help you do it's
a bidet that attaches right to your
toilet
at home
spray
and pat dry it installs in less than 10
minutes even if you don't know what
you're doing
yeah believe it or not this stuff now is
available for all of us in our home it
saves money pretty quick because that
toilet paper adds up you can give the
gift of a clean bum to yourself or your
loved ones this holiday season and get
10 percent off plus free shipping right
now at hellotushi.com yang
that's hellotushy.com yang for 10 off
and free shipping better ways to do
things you do every day that's what
we're about
[Music]
you know when you said it's like the
population of pennsylvania disappearing
from the workforce i thought of a bad m
night shyamalan movie it was like the
happening the great resignation by uh
i used to love that guy's movies um you
know we sort of hid yeah until he made
horror movies that were about uh right i
i believe is that is that happening the
one where spoiler alert it was the tree
yeah that was the
trees a little bit before she became
like a you know a huge star i think she
was sort of
an upward comer at that point um
yeah so there is an optimistic way to
look at folks moving and and having a
chance to reset
um
i feel like a lot of people right now
are in the figuring out mode and it's
kind of too early to tell whether it's
going to be an awesome thing or a less
awesome thing
certainly i'm doing this
podcast from new york city in new york
city
uh
emptied out to a significant significant
extent and then like a lot of people
have come back but the offices
aren't fully open the last number i saw
was that
maybe 20 something percent are hybrid
now
and eight percent are back in the office
five days a week uh here in new york
city
that's very low um certainly the stuff
i'm hearing from various technology
companies is they pulled their workers
and said what do you want to do
their workers said
work remotely
[Laughter]
the firms that said okay how about
coming to the office two days a week and
then
um there's been some hemming and hawing
and a certain
proportion of workers have done that and
firms are scared because if they were to
be hard asses
they're afraid that people would jet um
and one of the tough dynamics is that
the most confident employable workers
are the ones who will feel the most
flexible and ditching you for another
company because like i can just go you
know across the figurative street
and get employed uh by someone else
those these are exactly the people you
don't want to lose so so you have been
bending over backwards and saying people
can work remotely is this consistent
with the stuff you've been hearing and
do we think that remote work is here to
stay and then what does that mean like
are we happy about that i'm sure a lot
of people listening to this are happy
about that i think it's absolutely here
to stay i think it's important to be
clear about who
it's here to stay for right so
white-collar workers are already a
minority of the workforce and those that
can or already working remotely uh are
also a minority of that minority right
so it's not a it's not a huge number of
people relative to the overall economy
that are remotely but it's still
millions and millions of people and my
whole thing in remote work when i'm
having conversations uh about it i've
been doing a lot of writing and thinking
about it is
the theme here
is small changes can have big effects
small changes can have big effects let's
just assume
that only say 10 to 20
of white-collar workers knowledge
workers right media marketing uh stuff
you can do with a computer let's assume
there's only 10 20 of them continue to
work remotely for the foreseeable future
on the one hand that means 80 of them
are going back to the office for the
most part right so some people are going
to say oh look remote work it failed
but the 10 to 20 difference is huge
if let's say you live in new york if new
york subway ticket
sales decline by let's say you know 7 to
12
that is potentially devastating for the
city of new york if you have offices
that are 20 always 20 at least and by
the by the way you're kind of you know
like you're being very very conservative
these estimates i mean because right now
it's actually reversed where the offices
are 20 occupied and 80 unoccupied but
continue
at you're exactly right i'm i'm trying
i'm starting with the conservative take
and trying to prove just how dramatic
even the conservative take is exactly
what you said so let's say the offices
are 20 30 40 empty for the foreseeable
future that's massive
for consumer rents for commercial rents
that's a massive deal for businesses in
downtown urban areas that benefit from
all of the work lunches that are sold
when the offices are filled or all the
window shopping that people do when they
are walking between offices on their way
to work so
my big thing here again is small changes
can have big effects the spillover
effects of a 10
remote work revolution could be
absolutely meant yeah and you're you're
seeing a much more significant uh
percentage than that in a lot of places
and i will say i walked
new york's fifth avenue the other day
uh a lot of the stores are now open
again so that's good there are some
store fronts that have been clearly
refurbished and invested in
um but the
crowd size is lower than it has been
it's almost entirely tourists there's
still a lot of
empty
blackened out
retail storefronts
and so
you can see
the ongoing impact in a place like new
york most clearly
the folks i know who
have been working remotely for the most
part are still
either working remotely or back in the
office 40 percent of the time
and
you saw this massive repricing
of a lot of suburbs and exurbs here in
new york
here
in the city you haven't seen a collapse
in prices rents did come back
um
but
there is still a shoe to drop you feel
because people still don't know what the
new equilibrium is
and when i was running for mayor i was
making a case for
a continuation of
uh the
centrality of urban downtowns and
corridors now that i'm not running for
mayor
look up and be like oh you know i i see
that there's been a massive
uh migration uh and
work culture shift that does seem like
it's here to stay
um does that does this mean tough times
for densely populated air populated
areas relative to
lower cost uh suburbs excerpts there are
all these stories on the internet that i
think are driven somewhat by frankly
you know
young person journalistic bias about
people just moving to the woods or
moving to boise or whatever it is
so but what are the facts showing in
terms of
a real
uh reallocation of
energy
uh human capital
uh workforces to less densely populated
areas yeah this is a great complicated
question let me try to answer in an
organized way so let's begin with
research um nicholas bloom who's an
economist at stanford publishes really
interesting research at the end of 2020
about what he called the donut effect
and the donut effect is this idea that
in many rich metros
real estate prices grew
at the sort of outer suburbs of the
metro and they declined in the middle so
if you were going to draw a graph of
where
where real estate prices grew you would
be drawing essentially a doughnut around
the downtown area right that was by at
the end of 2020.
i think right now if you look at a lot
of downtown areas you know i was
recently in tribeca in new york and it
felt it felt uh pretty bumping um i
think you're starting to see people come
back
new york just saw the the highest rent
increase
in the city's history last month i
believe it was something like 18 year
over year uh in in in just the last
month so people are clearly moving back
to new york enough that they're
demanding that you know enough that
their their demand is pushing up um
pushing up brent's in the urban core um
but i do think that
to a certain extent if you take the
remote work thesis seriously which i
obviously do
it's going to be a little bit
complicated for some of these dense rich
downtown areas like san francisco and
new york and washington dc because
there's lots of reasons to live in these
cities
there's so much fun the restaurants are
amazing the culture's fantastic but one
of them is
i'm willing to pay a leg and an arm for
rent because my job forces me to be here
and if you yeah you're gonna get better
economic opportunities being there you
know it's like yeah your proximity and
then uh you can talk yourself into it
because you're like well my by being
here uh you know i'll get that many
times over in terms of even my uh career
opportunities
exactly you just take that away and it
means that everything else on the menu
for where you want to live in a city
right
housing prices and commute length and um
how large your house is and the
restaurants and proximity to family all
those other things can suddenly be
really really meaningful so i just think
a lot of people at the margin are going
to make a determination they don't need
to live in downtown areas whereas
previously in the 2018-2019 world they
thought that they did and that's going
to mean that there's a second and third
tier of cities that's going to grow
faster than it would in an alternate
reality where there was no pandemic
pulse that taught us all these lessons
about remote work so
upshot my theory here is i don't think
that san francisco is done i don't think
new york is done washington dc has done
but i do think i do think you should be
bullish on the second and third tier of
cities throughout the country because
more americans that otherwise were
tethered to their jobs in san francisco
and new york are going to realize
especially in their 30s uh i can kind of
move to another city if i really want to
um and they're going to do it derrick
you know what this means you should
start
a wreath that goes around buying all of
this real estate in second-tier cities
[Music]
this is why you're the business guy and
i'm the journalist i i i make the meager
journalist salaries and um you're you're
thinking like an investor i i agree and
i'm sure that you know the you know
your black rocks and black stones and um
other financial uh institutions that
have the word black in them um are all
looking at opportunities to to get into
buying in in second and third tier
cities it is a sure sign of
multi-billion dollar success if your
investment firm has uh black one word
title so black sword black shield just
waiting for us
uh derek you and me
we've already identified it so you
referenced something about age 30s
family et cetera et cetera like um so
how old are you
so
all right so check it out like i moved
to the city when i was 21 straight out
of college and you would put up with all
sorts of nonsense in your 20s
like being here
you're at a sweet spot when you're 35
like you have friends who are now
starting to uh have families and and
ditch the city you live in dc is that
right i do i live in downtown washington
dc yeah so you're at the sweet spot
where there are a bunch of folks who
could go either direction you know what
i mean i feel like young people still
flock to cities just because it's like
oh you know you gotta have something to
do on thursday night and friday night
and me you know meet people and the rest
of it and so that they're back where i
was when you just put up with any
nonsense
[Laughter]
you like live on top of each other
shoebox like crazy roommate stories
whatever it's like all part of the
um you know the rights of passage uh
whereas
after you have a partner maybe a dog
maybe a child then it's like wait a
minute what's going on what am i doing
and i i think that's the population that
cities have to be concerned about
certainly i know a lot of families who
left new york city and i will say that
the families that have left new york
city
not many of them are clamoring to come
back
it's like like i talked to a friend the
other day who moved to connecticut and
he's like dude
like you know kinetic gets the bomb he
was like trying to talk me into
connecticut
so so i'm wondering since you're 35 like
what are you seeing and hearing from
within your own network oh yeah i i have
it it honestly spans it runs the gamut
uh i've got friends who are just like
your friends moving to connecticut who
are moving out of the city moving out of
the the new yorks and san francisco's
and into the suburbs like you know
moving into new jersey and places like
that i also have friends who live uh
in downtown areas that they they love
cities and they kind of want to stay um
you know at 35 you know my friends kids
are pretty young and as a result you
know they're they're not necessarily in
kindergarten first grade uh and i think
it makes it a little bit easier to stay
in a city at that point um but i grew up
in a suburb i love cities but can
totally see myself moving to the suburbs
and in many cases you can kind of think
that like
what the pandemic has done is it's just
like
accelerated life for a lot of people
like a lot of people that might have
said i'm gonna live in new york for five
years or you know moved out six months
into the pandemic um and people you know
like other friends of mine who were
thinking you know i'm gonna um move to
the suburbs in in the next decade they
said you know what i might as well take
this opportunity right now cause i'd
love to sort of have a lawn uh or
something so i think that i think that
you know my my friends are are
relatively uh conventional millennials
in the respect that they uh uh they have
lived in a city uh for their 20s and
early 30s um and they are eyeing the
suburbs for their 30s and 40s
so for the kind of work you do did you
think about it because you know you're a
journalist a podcaster you could
theoretically have decamped to
wherever the heck
was it or or is it the case that as a
journalist being in a place like dc is
still super helpful yeah being in dc is
helpful um i also know a lot of people
in dc i'm from the dc area uh so friends
and family here
i think um
you're saying people would miss you
derek you're saying you have you think
he would just keep
i'm staying for them um my feeling is
i'm just not in a rush uh i i know that
uh me living in the suburbs is something
that's eventually going to happen
whether it's in
oh so fatalistic derek it's like i'm the
kind of guy who you know look i i i
listen to coldplay and brit pop i like
lawns um and i'm a boring in-house
inside cat so like i i know that
eventually all of these sort of cultural
preferences in my life will eventually
lead me to the suburbs and i just feel
no need to rush it um i like the city as
long as i live here
[Music]
we all have doubts and deficiencies
where you're like oh man am i good at
that thing and one of the ways that you
can give yourself confidence is
skillshare i always feel better when i
actually know what i'm doing
[Laughter]
skillshare is a leading way to learn new
skills online they're a sponsor of our
podcast and i'm thrilled for it i
actually know
one of the co-founders who was genuinely
driven by helping people learn and today
you can take classes and everything from
how not to have a printer go off on your
i'm sorry i think it was worth this
printing station stuff
i wonder how long this is gonna go on
for
oh it's over sweet
you can learn design interior design
photography skills
email marketing how to be a better
podcaster i mean literally that's a
thing a skill share pretty much anything
you can envision that people are
interested in and want to get better at
it's available to you on skillshare and
it's incredibly expensive an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month explore your creativity at
skillshare.com yang and get a one month
free trial of premium membership you
know you can see if it works within one
month that's one month of a premium
membership at skillshare.com yang thanks
for sponsoring the episode skillshare
we're glad you do
[Music]
derek thompson work from home is here to
stay uh that's something that uh he's
thinking deeply about and so what does
that mean for
organizations you're saying look
second-tier cities are probably going to
have
some new people which i agree with uh
you're going to see a bit less
centralization
of
talent and human capital and
organizational energy yeah i do get the
sense that a lot of the big orgs are
shrugging and saying all right you want
to live there i guess we'll work with
that like they're losing that particular
tug of war um how do you feel about the
continuation of remote work are you
positive negative neutral i talked to a
lot of people who are negative on it
just to share that where people who run
organizations
unhappy
people obviously people who for example
run restaurants and retail
establishments in some of these areas
unhappy like how do you feel about it
i think that it depends on who you talk
to and there's a bunch of different sort
of spectra that you can look at right so
one of them is a psychological spectrum
uh introverts versus extroverts the
introverts wow you're getting deep here
derek wow continue i'm starting here i'm
starting here so like the introverts
that i know are so so happy with remote
work like they go to the office and what
do they experience in the office people
are consciously trying to talk to them
they're constantly trying to people
always yelling at them and bullying them
you know just being like freaking
introvert and then like taking their
their trapper keepers and throwing them
on the ground is that the way it's going
all of this yes and so they're thinking
like it is so much more calm and happy
when i'm at home like my mental health
has never been better so they're
obviously happy to stay home and not
commute into an office where they can be
you know assaulted with um impromptu
conversation at the same time the
exercise was so assaulted with impromptu
friendliness
definitely talking to an extrovert right
now um i would consider myself somewhere
in the middle i look i and i should also
say like for for the the briggs meyer
i mean you've written both you're
probably an introvert that's like a
general thing rule of mine is like if
someone had the patience to sit there
and write a book they're probably
introverted but continue you've written
you've written twice as many books as i
have sir so um i don't know if you would
consider yourself an introvert i am an
introvert anyone who who saw me as a kid
would know i'd just be sitting under a
tree reading some dragon lance now well
you know it wasn't exactly
so yeah the extra verses i know in my
life are like get me back to the office
like i get i get confidence
i feel good about myself when i'm
talking to people so that that's that's
no one to lord it over in their house
they just start yelling at their dog
being like listen to me i have thoughts
but speaking of
thoughts over your dog
i i also think that another spectrum
that's important is like um like lower
level employees mid-level employees and
managers right so i think managers want
to get back into the office
for the most part in my experience like
they they enjoy managing people in like
a live setting people that are kind of
advanced in their career but not
managers they're happy to work from
anywhere like they're really really
happy to have that freedom to not have
the commute
younger workers i think feel often like
they're missing out on culture if
culture to them is just a group slack if
it's just like if the office just
becomes
a group text that's not
an office that's
a group text and so i think that for
some like younger employees they aren't
getting
necessarily the cultural experience that
they want so i think it cuts a lot of
different ways and you know remote work
is one of these things that i sometimes
compare to like like food like it's
ridiculous to say that food is good or
bad some food is good for some people
some of the time and that's what we're
going to see with remote work that it's
it's going to be this unevenly
distributed thing that works for some
people and not for others and it's gonna
be particularly difficult i think for
ceos who are managing large companies
that have a
wide spectrum of psychological profiles
and diversion extroverts a wide spectrum
of workers young middle-aged and old
that's where the where the that you know
what's really going to hit the fan
because i think it's just going to be
really difficult um to to
find a solution that works for everybody
well i'm really with you derek and that
the people that i feel bad for are the
young workers who are coming up because
if you just came out of school and you
were trying to figure out how to prove
yourself in an organization
uh it's i think it's just harder or
to get a sense as to how to manage
people also probably harder because you
know you aspire to try and become that
manager at some point i'm going to share
something there is a 20-something year
old in my life uh
you know like a family member who's been
working from home
and i think is getting depressed as a
result
um now if you were to ask this person
hey would you prefer remote work or
going into the office they would say
remote work
now do i think that the remote work is
getting them pumped up on a day-to-day
basis or even developing them
professionally not really
but if you ask them their preference
they still would say well i prefer
working in my sweatpants to having to
commute like get dressed go the office
like do this thing
interact with those horrible other
people
face to face you know whatever it is
like you know if you
leave it up to them um
but i'm not sure that their preference
actually matches up to what would help
their uh career over the medium term or
even their day-to-day happiness uh like
uh and i i'm you know it's like i'm
somewhere in the zone too where like if
you're an advanced professional you can
work from anywhere and you have a family
like i do then you know it's like it
becomes very very appealing to say yeah
let me just beam in um but but i do feel
for that next generation what you're
pointing to is something that the uh the
psychologist dan gilbert has called miss
wanting
he has a book called stumbling on
happiness about
just various ways of thinking about our
eternal search for permanent happiness
which will never actually happen but
that's what makes it so fascinating to
think about and this term is wanting
refers the fact that lots of people
seem to tell themselves or tell
pollsters or tell
their family members
that um
they want a particular thing that
actually makes them miserable over the
long haul so i for example have a friend
who has a a theory about rich people
and he says i think rich people buy
loneliness with their money too often
that what happens when you get really
rich you might buy the private jet okay
that makes sense like no one likes
flying in coach they can fly in first
class on a private jet but they buy a
big house maybe in the middle of nowhere
and they'll buy you know a pierre terre
um in a city and they don't really want
to talk to people so they'll find
various ways to to make sure they never
have to to speak to people outside of
their network and they'll design this
perfectly insulated life that guarantees
that they aren't um what did i say
assaulted by impromptu conversation by
the unwashed masses
and as a result they'll feel
like they're missing something they'll
feel an aspect of isolation and so they
are miswanting
a a feeling of eliteness that is
actually conducive to loneliness and so
here you have examples in i guess either
end of the economic spectrum and
obviously miss wanting is not just
something that happens to elites i think
it happens to all of us um you know the
the sunday afternoon that that one
spends um watching eight hours of
netflix and then reflecting back that
huh i kind of wish i didn't spend eight
hours inside it would have been nice to
have taken a walk you miswanted that
that binge to a certain extent um i do
think that much to netflix's delight
um i do think there's something rather
rather profound about the about the
phenomenon of miss wanting and it's
possible that a lot of us you know
miss wants a lot of conveniences of
sort of interest it's just friction man
if you ask anyone like hey do you want
friction be like hell no and you know it
commutes friction other people are
friction the office is friction um but
it turns out that some degree of
friction is probably healthy you know
there are people that are trying to
discipline themselves in social media
and they like you know take the app off
their phone so they can't just freaking
pull it up they have to go through a
browser and some other stuff
you know it's like sometimes you
introduce friction
um but you can sell frictionlessness to
just about anyone and say hey do you
want to buy it and be like yeah yeah
yeah um and that relates to the
isolation factor too it's like other
people suck do you want to like you know
buy the gate be like yes
no you're a super villain do you want
the floating hideout where no one can
come assault you with their faces
um
so it's you know it's something that
uh
that i i think we're seeing in in
different ways is just so there's some
friction that we probably wanted that
that'd be my case and that might include
some elements of the in-person office
experience yeah the um the columbia
professor tim wu has written about this
uh that there are
certain ways that the
uh tech consumer economy can be so
perfectly frictionless that it can uh
remove some of the sort of the the small
inconvenient beauties that are just a a
part of life and sometimes i find that
to be too much of a traditionalist
argument but sometimes i think it's kind
of right like i think he was he wrote
this article for the new york times
about um like the joy of of wandering
through an antique shop not knowing what
you want that now if you want something
what you're supposed to do is that
that's some funny [ __ ] out of tim what
the hell is that about like you had to
choose an antique store i mean at least
my examples made sense
come on tim
i i might be misquoting i hope tim
doesn't get mad at me um but tim's now
like a senior white house appointee so
this is the kind of leaderships over in
these objectives
tim's a really good smart guy tip's a
really good smartphone he's gonna stick
the ftc on me um but yeah he was
pointing out that today you want
something and you just type it into your
phone um and you don't experience the
friction of uh of of looking for it um
of of having an exploratory experience i
suppose you could say and we're freaking
pen pals man old enough to remember that
[ __ ] where it takes like a week to get
the letter like that you know anyway
i don't want this to be too i don't want
to become too fuddy fuddy-duddy like i
am a huge fan of technology i'm a huge
fan of the friction points that have
been eliminated um by a lot of these
companies but clearly like there is
there is something that is wrong we all
we all feel it i think in our bones and
we can sometimes see it literally in the
statistics there is something wrong with
a life that is overly mediated by our
phones or that is overly mediated by
these technologies designed to produce
streams of frictionlessness you had this
graph in in your book
of the coincidence of the rise of
teenage anxiety and depression with the
mainstreaming of the smartphone this is
something jonathan hate has written
about psychologists at nyu a bunch of
other people are on this instagram is
even found in its own internal surveys
uh shocker
and they're just i i do i do see this
all as you know the all of these stories
as being a part of the same mega story
um that
tech is is awesome um and every and
these these apps are are wondrous in so
many ways um but there is something that
seemed to be removing from our lives
humanity brother
we freaking miss that humanity action
you know you gotta walk down the street
and find your friend as opposed to
seeing their best moments on your phone
and thus screwing with your mind
yeah
you and i are aligned on that point for
sure um you recently
uh
amplified an idea that scared the [ __ ]
out of me um and i want to share it with
everyone it's not your idea or maybe it
is i'll just share it
so there was a recent consumer
confidence survey
that said that 87 percent of democrats
think the economy is good or like
positive sentiment
while only 37 of republicans did and you
noted that this was the largest gulf
in terms of perception of
the economic trajectory between parties
that you had ever seen 50 percent
but then
even more troubling is that this wasn't
only on one side or the other that back
in 2019
the gulf actually cut the other
direction where republicans thought the
economy was great and democrats thought
it sucked by a margin of 47
and so this is something that scared the
[ __ ] out of me because what it showed
was that hey it turns out there is no
objective reality to the way we
experience the economy
and it's just that if my party is in
power i'm going to be more likely to
think good things than if the other
parties in power
uh
i think that's the point you were making
uh by by uh retweeting this is that
right i absolutely agree that that is
the clear takeaway um just to do i do a
half step back to to set it up because i
think that the the historical change is
really important so the university of
michigan has been doing this consumer
survey for like 60 70 years they
basically ask a bunch of people
how do you think the economy is going
and since the 1980s they've been
breaking it down democrat republican
independent right
between 1980
and
2017 there had never been more than a
30-point gap between the way democrats
and republicans saw the economy right
democrats republicans more or less
were co-occupants of reality right they
were experiencing something that we
could that they could agree good times
good times we were in the same place the
same economy
and since 2017 it's just gone completely
berserk that if a republican is the
president just about other republicans
say the economy is great and a lot of
the democrats say the economy is bad and
then when a democrat is president all
the democrats say that the economy is
good and all the republicans say the
economy is bad that's only a slight
exaggeration but that's basically what
we started to see and it basically means
exactly what you said that we used to
partially decide whether or not we
thought our party was doing a good job
by first looking to the economy but now
we decide if the economy is good by
first looking to the party that's in
power ideology is the
pair of glasses that everybody is
wearing and as a result you might not as
well even ask people how good the
economy is you might as well just tell
them hey do you like biden or not
because once once i hear the answer to
that question everything else that i ask
you about reality will simply flow
downstream of that comment and it just
goes to this point which again you write
about in your book and i have a couple
questions about your book which i
thought was really really interesting
which is that polarization has just
eaten up american democracy and i don't
i don't know what the path out of it is
you have started to hoe your specific
path out of it which is forming a third
party um but man it is so hard to be a
political optimist when
we don't share the same reality on a
question as simple as how is the economy
yeah i thought that was very profound
and frightening that it's veered so
sharply
into the ideological zone
uh you wrote recently
that democrats are getting crushed in
what you call the vibes war
which i think was by the way correct
uh i think they underestimate the fact
that
there is a vibes war and
uh that
going back and forth within your own
party was a bad look
um some of the things i don't genuinely
find them that you know
like i i think that we're in a point in
american history where politicians
regularly take blame for stuff they had
nothing to do with they also take credit
for things that nothing to do with um so
so some of the vibes of war uh
is out of their control um but some of
it has been um and
it is really really hard to see what the
path forward can look like because
you're gonna make an argument now on the
infrastructure bill which by the way i
love and you know i think that the
republicans who voted for it were doing
the right thing and the fact that
they're getting attacked for it now for
political and ideological reasons is
terrible
um but the toughest part then is that
the entire foundation of the argument
you make which is look we passed this
bill it's been good for you in terms of
roads and jobs and economic activity
people will be like i don't care about
any of that like you know like i just
care about
the reality as it's presented to me by
my favorite news channel or favorite
commentators and then they can tell me
how to feel
about what's going on in the ground
[Music]
this is a tough time for just about
everyone but you should not take it
lying down you should do something about
it and one way you can do something
affirmative that is sure to help your
mental health and your day-to-day
happiness is betterhelp.com
your friends and family are not equipped
to listen to you vent all the time and
you feel bad if you're a conscientious
person you feel bad after
approximately one day of venting your
loved ones so who should you talk to a
professional licensed therapist who is
there to meet your needs you can
schedule them on demand this is not
self-help this is better help thrilled
to have them sponsor the podcast
thrilled to send our listeners their way
because this stuff works shocker talking
to a therapist is a good thing and
better help is the way to do it that
fits in with your lifestyle and your
budget i want you to start being happier
today and as a listener you'll get 10
percent off your first month by visiting
our sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang join over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health you
do not need to be sad and take it lying
down that's betterhelphelp.com
yang get yourself some help your loved
ones will be glad you did
[Music]
yeah this is where i really wanted to
talk to you actually um so uh
you have am i allowed to is this is this
horrifyingly embarrassing for me if i
read to you from your own book
very much
all right so um page 249 um i think this
is a really really profound point
you write in the book open versus closed
political science book um a bunch of
political psychologists ask
ask responders to talk about um to
respond to various various opinions they
found that disengaged citizens had less
of a fixed political identity based upon
their psychological profile they were
more pragmatic and practical when
presented with a question they reacted
to a policy by trying to answer what
will this policy do for me
meanwhile those who were more
politically attentive were more likely
to try to answer
what will supporting this policy say
about me they were joining a group
what's so interesting about this
observation
is that you would think that people who
were engaged with politics might be
thinking economically
but they're not at all the people
disengaged with politics are thinking
economically
and the people engaged with politics are
thinking culturally
and as more of america becomes more
politically engaged this might be
another uh scare the [ __ ] out of you a
moment andrew as more of america becomes
politically engaged
this research suggests that the future
of politics is a culture war
not a what will this policy do for me
not a what will biden do for the broken
road and the broken bridge and the bad
broadband in my zip code but rather what
does it mean to my facebook group to my
neighborhood bible study group if i
support this president's bill
that is
terrifying that the future of politics
is so post-material and so cultural that
storytelling essentially
uh subsumes actual policy details
politics has become content derek i'm
very very scared of it too and what you
characterize as a vibes war
is not the aside it's actually the
center
it's actually hey let's like engage in a
vibes war and like see who can convince
50.1 percent of the population that uh
you know we're on track um
i i also was very moved by that research
and
i referenced jonathan height uh fairly
heavily i reference ezra klein fairly
heavily like some of their
insights were what led me to head this
direction and start the forward party
because i looked up and was like okay
if it really is just gonna come down to
tribalism and not whether i can
demonstrate that my policies are going
to help you
then where does that lead and it leads
to by the way civil war 2.0
and then what is the path out
and the path out to me is one to start a
unifying
positive political tribe but also to try
and break up the two tribes so that
they're
they're like five six or seven tribes
and then in in that landscape then if
you have these relatively ideological
communications lanes at least you're not
going to get 50 of people you know like
i can inflame a certain time which by
the way would also lead to something
that i imagine you're for which is a
much more
diverse
media landscape where it's not that you
have an apparatus that's just augmenting
the republican point of view and talking
points and then they're like you know
the democrat but that there's some other
universe and i would say that you're one
of actually the leaders of this universe
which is you try and find objective
reality
you try to like present it to people
in this way it'd be like reality-based
journalism which you know a lot of
journalists right now imagine that
they're practicing but uh
but
i'm not sure they are
that that's you are i'm gonna say this
that's a high compliment coming from me
i really appreciate that i i really do
um i sincerely appreciate that i really
do try
to tell the truth
and um it sounds ridiculous and uh
cliche to say that
i want to tell the truth but i really
really do and a part of
i think really wanting
to
tell the truth as an occupation
means just downshifting rather
dramatically what tribe or what corner
of the political spectrum the truth
seems to be coming from
so right now for example
we've got inflation
inflation's inflation's here it's really
high in energy it's pretty high in meat
and poultry and it's pretty high in carb
prices
now there are a lot of republicans that
are saying completely wrong things about
inflation like we're why am i republic
like inflation's 20 like we're about to
spiral into you know a german venezuela
territory
that's all [ __ ] obviously that's
complete [ __ ]
at the same time i really do see a lot
of liberals and i'm not i'm not i'm not
trying to do both sides here i'm just
saying it's unfortunate the degree to
which
lots of people in the media now seem to
be putting ideology over evidence i see
lots of liberals
sort of poo-pooing the idea that anyone
would care about inflation that it's
basically just a republican psyop it's
like it's not just republican psyop the
like the the bureau of labor statistics
is telling you in its own words this is
the highest inflation rate in 30 years
let's believe them these are these are
non-partisan economists believe reality
and
i i have found it i i do think that the
the fact that media has become so
ideological
is unfortunately
downstream of the fact that media has
become so abundant
we are like you know
we're like plants in the jungle we're
like plants in a rainforest we are
diversifying and and becoming specific
and different
because we need to do so to survive
and you're seeing everyone feeling like
they have to have an antagonistic
relationship with the rest of media like
how often do you hear like people in the
media say the media is broken well of
course they are because their job is to
win an audience within the media
consuming public that thinks that they
are the only voices telling the truth
like to a certain extent someone could
have accused me of doing this the
beginning of this answer right like
right is wrong left is wrong only i am
telling the truth i don't want to say
that
but at the same time this is just what
i'm saying is the the character of the
media that you are observing
is downstream of the
media economy which is so abundant that
there are there's so many people
clamoring for attention that we all have
to tell we all have to have some version
of the same message
everyone else is lying except for me
come to me for the truth
for the truth country for the truth and
you will live and um and that does make
it i think very difficult
to to be non-ideological um and i i
honestly don't have a i wish i had a
quick solution to that problem um i i
frankly don't i don't know if you see
this the same way that i do
i see it exactly the same um and i'm
working on a solution believe it or not
in true yang in fashion
well my solution and there'll be more to
come on this uh is to try to augment
and properly resource independent voices
that have developed a trusted following
based upon some degree of loyalty and
adherence to the truth uh people like
you frankly uh you know and i could
throw out some other names i'm just
gonna throw out a couple names just so
people have a sense of where i'm going
with this but like crystal ball and
sagar
and jetty they've developed a following
as independent trustworthy voices uh i i
want to help make these voices the new
uh network the new mainstream and so i'm
working on trying to make that happen
uh we'll see if if i can be successful
certainly i want to be a part of trying
to
give us a chance to come back and have a
sense of reality and have a sense of
accountability to the truth and i don't
see a way to do that without making it
so that the
resources and incentives are flowing in
the right direction yeah i think from a
political perspective i wonder how you
see the challenge of winning the
storytelling battle
you have this um you made this
observation that you printed in the book
you said the democratic party which with
i i think you're you're often
politically aligned but i do see the why
you're interested in forming a third
party you see the democratic party has
taken on this role of the urban coastal
elites who are more concerned about
policing various cultural issues than
improving the working classes way of
life that's been declining um
say a little bit more about about that
argument and what what you disagree with
the democratic party's approach to
talking about cultural issues well that
quotes from a cnn clip that was pretty
widely recirculated but it was born in
my experience talking to a waitress at a
diner in iowa
where i said hey running for president
and she said oh what party and i said
democrat and then it's like i sprouted
horns or a tail or turned purple or
something
so like that the democratic party has
really been coded in a certain way for a
lot of people and if you were generous
you would say oh it's because of you
know fox and conservative talk radio and
i'm sure there's some truth to that um
but it does seem to a lot of
working-class americans that are met
that the democratic party does not care
about whether their lives are good or
bad
um and
that's a losing place to be if you're
the democratic party which theoretically
is supposed to be i thought for the
working class and the little guy in
little gal and so then the question is
well what do these people think the
democratic party is about and they think
it's about the language they think it's
about culture they think it's about
things that
educated people in cities care about
more than folks who are in iowa or
indiana or new hampshire
so
that that was the critique i had and
still do have and and to me the goal
should be to try and get policies across
the finish line and it doesn't matter
what i call it i mean it's one reason
why you called universal basic income
the freedom dividend um because it
tested better and it tested better
frankly with conservatives
like i i used to tell the story derek
where uh
everything tested about the same with
people who were on the left you called
it universal basic income
prosperity dividend social security for
all it was all about the same by the way
back then it wasn't that high
i mean it started out at 27 approval now
it's like 65. um but we called it the
freedom dividend because it worked more
with more people and you have to ask
yourself it's like why is it that
democrats uh aren't able to make this
the same adjustment which is so obvious
it's like hey if you talk about
something in a certain way they hate it
so it's like maybe talk about it another
way and the democratic stubbornness
seems to be like no
if if they aren't liking this then then
their ears are wrong
or their minds are wrong they're not
receptive enough to like the language
i'm using and by the way they exacerbate
that because they like change the
language all the time but you know
they're really excited it's like you
know i'm pretty hyped and savvy to this
stuff it's like even i have trouble
keeping track of what you know like what
the vocabulary is
[Laughter]
it's like trying to reach people where
they are so anyway
that was what my my point was yeah right
no i th that the vocabulary they use can
be alienating i can i absolutely i can
absolutely see that to what extent do
you think
universal basic income right now
and popularity of ubi has been affected
by the pandemic stimulus checks well you
see the appeal of universal basic income
rising and i got two main objections
when i was on the trail number one is
where are we going to get the money and
number two is
people aren't going to use it well
and now people realize we actually
always had the money
and of the literally you know
160 million americans who've gotten some
form of cash relief over this last
number of months they know how they
spent it which was on
food and fuel and car repairs and school
supplies and the rest of it or the folks
who are continuously getting the child
tax credit right now
so because of lived experience a lot of
people like oh
like we really can do this and oh it
doesn't turn
everyone into a different human being
[Laughter]
so
um so i i feel like this time period has
only accelerated the eventual adoption
of ubi
um and
i think it's just going to continue to
be become the policy solution as dozens
of mayors around the country including
in some really big cities are now
launching various versions and pilots
[Music]
there was an early objection to
universal basic income that said it's
going to change the way that people
spend their money and spend their time
they're going to become lazy they're not
going to work and instead everything
that i've read seems to point in the
opposite direction that in fact what you
have in the developing world the sort of
ascending developing world is you have a
lot of poverty traps people quote
unquote act poor not because of biology
psychology culture because of money they
are in poverty traps they they need
money and if they had money they could
be unbelievably productive and happy and
and i i love the idea of of leading of
leading with ubi um to what extent do
you is it still the centerpiece of of
the forward party um is it is it is just
the core is it the entree um or is it um
are there other other things that have
joined the plate well it's very much
there front and center when you go to
forwardparty.com you see there are a
number of core principles and universal
basic incomes right there
uh i you know i'm frankly mr ubi
so which i'm very proud of you know it's
like having someone say to me on the
street like hey yang
literally i get thanked for people's
cash relief checks i mean that's a
pretty wonderful feeling
so it's right there what's interesting
derek is i ran for president thinking
the problem was that people didn't know
about ubi and so i needed to
spread the idea
and now i think the problem is that our
government isn't responsive to the will
of the average person and so that's what
the democracy reform elements of the
forward party are about around open
primaries and right choice voting
uh so
if universal basic income is for example
a solution or a vision
uh now the forward party is about trying
to make it a reality and you could in my
opinion swap out any of a number of big
things for universal basic income and it
would fit in similarly
climate change you know and trying to
address it like i think that's something
that a lot of americans are frustrated
by our relative inaction
like our system right now is built for
polarization dysfunction stagnation
frustration eventual you know it's like
you could you could put in just about
any big
policy goal negative asian yeah yeah
yeah like you can
it's like what uh francis fukuyama
called the vitocracy it's like i can i
can't do anything but i can keep you
from doing anything um which in a time
of rapid
change is terrible you know and then
it's related to the gerundocracy which i
i talk about a little bit and you know
some people aren't into the fact that i
characterize it as such but it really is
i mean you know we're probably careening
towards a biden trump rematch in 2024
and their combined age will be 158 you
know it's like people look up be like oh
my gosh like we're doing this again
it's not going to be
fantastic so let me let me assume that i
am and this is not a
huge or unrealistic assumption assume
that i am exactly the demographic that
you're trying to reach i am mad at the
gerontocracy and think that america's
leaders are way too old i'm mad at the
vitocracy francis fukuyama's vitocracy
and think it's way too difficult to
build anything or do anything the
moonshots are over
and we don't have any ambitious plans
for government-funded technology anymore
unless we're in a pandemic
i want a government that is pro-tech and
pro-science but also pro-egalitarianism
i want us to care about people um and
the ubi i think is a wonderful way to
express that care all of this i'm on
your team at the same time
i remember
ross perot i remember ralph nader i know
the history of third parties in america
and they can often cannibalize from the
party the party that you are most like
this this has to be something that
you've been asked and some that you've
thought about a lot how do you worry
about that risk yeah well i appreciate
all of the affinities you just expressed
eric it's super exciting uh so there are
a number of things i would say is that
number one we have to figure out how
we're going to transition from this
broken down duopoly to something better
and more effective
and the path there in my opinion is just
trying to make it so that independent
points of view can come up regardless of
what those points of view are
so
uh to me
the forward party is going to enable
a multi-party system by trying to make
the system frankly not shut out anyone
who's not
an r or a d
um if you want to get into brass tacks
about some of the examples you've been
cited ross perot led to clinton winning
uh you know i mean he got nineteen point
three percent of the vote oh i mean ross
perot stole from
both much from republicans yeah go ahead
though
yeah yeah i know so so it it and you
could look at andrew yang and say oh
like you know this
uh
this guy or like this party is naturally
like more demi um there are some facts
that actually cut the other way where 42
percent of my supporters when i was
running as a democrat in the democratic
presidential nomination
uh said they weren't sure they were
they're going to support the democratic
nominee if it weren't me um and so
that's almost half at a time when
frankly i had a big d next to my name
everywhere i went
like that there were
a lot of people i encountered on the
trailer were like hey yang
you know would totally support him if he
wasn't a democrat
and if you look at the appetite for a
third party right now it's actually
significantly higher among both
independents and republicans than it is
among democrats so it's an empirical
open question uh where the energy would
come from the other thing is that
people that
tend to fast forward to just the
presidential race this 2024
question
and
there are a lot of things we can do at
the local level at the state level like
we did in alaska around uh i mean i
didn't do it like alaska did
around switching to
open primaries and ranked choice voting
um which it's good for democracy it's
good for sanity and reasonableness to
just have better incentives so there are
all of these things i would push people
towards and say look even if you're
concerned about let's say the 2024
election let's table that do as much as
we can
in the here and now let's call it 22
and then if we are heading in a
direction where you're like uh oh i'm
concerned about empirically tipping the
election in a direction i don't like
then we can examine it then but we're
nowhere near that point right now i'm
sympathetic to the argument i think that
you know
we see internationally that countries
that have
first passed the post
electoral democracies do tend to become
two-party
systems and that's exactly what we have
and it's made it very very difficult for
third parties um in in the us to get
started i would i would love a
proliferation of parties i think it
would help so many
surprising
second order things like for example
political polarization if everyone can
just sort themselves by saying i'm
against or i'm for joe biden and i'm
going to describe the economy that way
and i'm going to see reality that way
it's it's too easy it's it's it's too
easy i think to have that sort of you
know head-to-head death match
but when partisanship is scrambled a
little bit when there are five parties
six parties seven parties then there's
more of a competition
to not just be against something but
before the right thing because
everyone's against everything but maybe
you're maybe you're you're you you
specialize may come for something for a
really really um uh particularly
persuasive argument
so i i love the idea
right now derek you can see the
animating force for both parties is
hating the other party
uh well look i think i think the book is
really really interesting and um uh i i
wanted the last question i want to ask
you that was related to the book is um
you know you
i have no idea what it's like to run for
president you make this really funny
comment that um a lot of people think
that only narcissists run for president
and uh it may be true that most people
that run for president are somewhat
narcissistic but the actual experience
of running for president is just one
humble pie after another it's just this
ego smashing exercise where
one media beats up at you uh someone
insults you uh it's it just seemed
really really difficult i wonder from
that experience like
on the other end of the media equation
what you see as the political media's
biggest flaws in this country
i think the political media's biggest
flaw is that they
feel themselves to be the arbiter of
what narrative gets included and what
does not uh and i use in the book the
example of joe sestak who was an admiral
in the navy
and was eminently qualified to talk
about certainly
uh foreign policy and defense-related
issues and the media wouldn't give the
time of day because he wasn't quote
unquote serious
i heard from any number of people i had
an interview with barry weiss the other
day and she said that new york times
journalists would regularly exclude me
from coverage of a debate or the
campaign and when asked hey why not have
yang on there they would say like yang
is not serious um and then and then i
when i talked to barry about it i was
like hey
how does a reporter know whether i'm
serious and then the answer is other
reporters
there's like a circularity um going on
and so i i i wish that political media
would just show up and be like treat
themselves like an alien being like okay
what what's going on like who's this
what's that um the problem is that right
now a lot of journalists have
pre-existing connections with folks who
are already in office or who've been in
politics for a long time so there'll be
this continuous
uh
treatment of certain people as um more
legitimate or worthy of consideration
than others and on my campaign we talked
all the time about how the media was
trying to make a particular person a
thing
you could almost see like the media
gotta turn towards it i don't think i
you know it's like uh i i think that
um
we had like a very strange set of
experiences where the media is concerned
but i wish that folks would
would in some ways take themselves less
seriously you know what i mean like like
not like oh if i
um somehow expose my
readers or viewers to this then like
it's my signing off on them it's like
look just bring people on
uh and let voters decide that there's
some asymmetry in this too derek where
uh i think that
yeah i think that one side is better
than other than the other at trying to
get out of the way um so that that would
be my my thought on it but i'm glad you
read
and took an interest in that part of the
book running for president certainly was
a bizarre set of experiences i don't
think most people understand what it's
like and so i tried to uh break it down
in a way that most people could relate
to and hopefully i thought it was so
interesting how the the the combination
of
what must be utterly exhilarating
moments and utterly boring moments that
that you must that you must go between
that speaking in front of a crowd being
on primetime tv on a stage
to audition to be the most powerful
person in the world like that just must
be an extraordinary thrill and at the
same time because you are on the trail
all the time just the tr the travel the
mind-numbing
hours of just going between i'm sure
wonderful cities but like i'm exhausted
when i fly across the country once like
to have that be your life for a year and
a half just must be
totally enervating and so i just i just
found that that it it opened my eyes the
fact that you must have there must be
really high highs followed by lows
followed by highs and it must just
really sort of
churn your insides and um uh be a really
sort of psychologically discombobulating
experience
well derek you just hope there are some
really high highs man i mean like that
the thing i i compare my experience to
is like uh
where you show up to a town
and then there's like a small group and
then you give them your message or your
stuff and then you hope that they like
it
and then you literally come back to that
town
a number of months later and you're like
you hope that the crowd is bigger
[Laughter]
so so when you talk about like the high
highs none of the highs were guaranteed
on the yang campaign you know what i
mean you know like there's no guarantee
i'd be on that debate stage there's no
guarantee there'd be a crowd waiting for
me
it was it was all and there weren't
crowds waiting for me to your point
early on like i'd show up and there'd be
nobody there and you know the people
that were there would not take you
seriously because you'd be like hey i'm
running for president and they'd be like
really
uh you know like i i managed to run the
gamut of experiences where
the one one thing that just pops to mind
i attended the iowa state fair
in 2018 i'd already declared
and it was
really really
uh punishing on a certain level because
no one cared no one believed like i had
a young idealistic staffer with me who
like urged me to just like run up to
people and like introduce myself i was
like look i'm really not going to just
like mess with other people's like trip
to the fair just to like stick my face
in theirs be like hey i remember
like like let's just get some lemonade
and
turkey leg and try and like act like
human beings here uh and then i came
back to that same fair
the following year and there was this
phalanx of camera people around me and a
video camera the rest of it and people
had heard of me because you know i'd
been on a debate stage or whatnot uh and
so
um like the experience was different uh
but there was no guarantee we'd ever get
to the second version of it you know
what i mean like so when you talk about
like the highest high it's like it was
just a grind for a long time
um and even in the
headier days of the campaign to your
point you would wake up in a best
western and get up early and then do a
local radio interview and then get back
in a rental vehicle and just try and you
know put your best foot forward
it must be it must be exhausting it's
exhausting to think about i have one
more question just about running for
president um
and maybe it's a weird question i don't
know if you've been asked this before
anything you do
for a long time you get better at like
you don't have to go full ten thousand
hours theory malcolm gladwell to believe
that as you do something
for more hours you tend to get a little
bit better at it
what is this skill that you think you
improved on the most
running for president
like the skill set of running for
president to me is totally bewildering
but like you've done it
what what are you better at now than you
were four years ago i am better at
performing derek uh and i think i
referenced this in the book um but
you do get reps
uh i
hated these cable news appearances so
much when you're staring at this red dot
and you're pretending to have a
compelling conversation with someone i
even i thought to myself afterwards i
was like it's not like i'd watch one of
those cable news hits and they're like i
should be president
so i like turned to my team and be like
hey do i even have to do these they're
so awful
uh
and months later when cnn actually
signed me up as a contributor
uh and i was on air i'd be like i hated
these i suck at these and now apparently
like i must not be that terrible because
i you know news network decided that
they'd like more of it
so
you guys like what i got better at i got
better at performing in different types
of environments i got better at staring
at a news camera i got better at talking
to
10 people 100 people a thousand people
i got better at trying to hold an arena
you know and if you look online like
there were speeches i gave to arenas of
uh of sometimes you know like not yang
gang it'd be like random democratic
voters uh and so you get these reps and
now uh my wife jokes too it's like if i
have a speaking gig now like they'll
throw me out and in the spectrum of my
performance
uh you know experience it's like okay
this group's like 500 people or whatever
it's like you know 500 people it's not
that big a deal whereas
like you know rewind earlier and be like
500 people that'd be incredible that's
fascinating um well andrew this has been
so interesting thank you so much for
having me on the podcast
[Music]
you